prosecutors in Atlanta have charged
nearly two dozen people with domestic
terrorism they're accused of attacking
the construction site of a controversial
training facility for police and
firefighters on Sunday authorities say
demonstrators were armed with rocks and
Molotov cocktails its latest flare-up
over the project that activists call cot
City Skyler Henry reports from Georgia
where accused protesters are being held
aerial footage shows the group of
demonstrators many wearing masks and
holding Shields swarming the Atlanta
Public Safety Training Center hurling
fireworks at police officers and
lighting construction equipment on fire
this wasn't about a Public Safety
Training Center this was about Anarchy
and this was about the attempt to
destabilize police say 35 people were
arrested in the incident though 11 were
released without charges and one was
hospitalized of the remaining 23 who
faced domestic Terror charges only two
are from Georgia and just one is from
Atlanta the current plan will heighten
tensions and harm communities for
decades Community organizers appeared at
Monday's Atlanta City council meeting to
voice their objections to the facilities
the council approved by a 10-4 vote in
September 2021
a broad Coalition opposes the project
ranging from environmentalists concerned
about the potential destruction of
Atlanta's South River Forest to local
civil rights leaders who say the project
will further militarize police it all
goes together because none of our issues
stand alone Kiana Jones is a reverend in
East Atlanta and was among the people to
speak at Monday's city council meeting
we are opening our mouths and crying
with a loud voice to say that we don't
want cop City Jones told us she was
stunned by protesters violence Sunday
especially in contrast to what she
described as safe Community oriented
events we are not sparing mayor Andre
Dickens or this Council for one moment
we are holding them accountable
January law enforcement shot and killed
a demonstrator who was living on the
site's grounds
prompting widespread outcry officers
claim the protesters shot at them first
at the time Atlanta's mayor defended the
training facility and said it was
answering a call from constituents to
improve policing following Nationwide
civil rights protests in the summer of
2020. they don't want to see the very
things that they asked for more police
training we can't train imaginary we
have to do it in a facility that allows
for police firefighters in the community
to train together
um
now mayor Dickens has also said that
while the training facility will be
built on 85 Acres of forest land some
300 acres will be preserved now as for
the incident that happened on Sunday
police say no officers were injured in
the incident they also say they will be
standing by should any protest this week
become violent Tony
all right Skyler got it thank you very
much